lake toho in Baneen is to become part of
the mono delta trans-boundary biosphere
reserve in Togo and Benin pantry is
badder and his environmental
organization Africa mobile nature are
working to create the future reserve
badder would like to set up the Nature
Reserve on the riverbanks and on the
water rare flora and fauna exists in the
wetlands but what does conservation mean
to the fishermen and hunters they used
to hunt monkeys in antelope here Patrice
badder encounters a local hunting patrol
now they're being paid to protect the
area from poachers badder says he's glad
of that I say unfair after all this
region is theirs and they have to
protect it here is no longer how long we
used to sell the game or eating
ourselves but we've given up all that we
want the wild animals to be still around
for our children to see the population
of Benin and Togo is growing rapidly and
more and more land is being urbanized
local residents are also burning down
trees to clear land for farming we fly
to our next stop a new biosphere reserve
in the forest of God GMA in neighbouring
Togo for the people in this area the
forest is sacrosanct they head out into
the woods following their priests in a
procession they believe that God's of
the forest can heal them from sickness
and provide protection from evil the
priests have always kept close guard on
the forest but now they're being
supported by a local environmental group
priest vodoun back bow says they want to
reforest some areas and set up a patrol
guard okay brah i vant OU koi pond you
bay to vote on it
the greatest threats to the forest our
land clearance and farming a Timberland
together they are working to fight
illegal hunting forest burning and
timber thieves environmental
organizations are helping local people
to protect key areas in both Benin and
Togo preserving both long-standing human
traditions and the environment